welcome to this video playing beyond
madness okay let's see how how mad he
can get again i forgot to play the Dutch
I take those requests seriously but
sometimes yeah this guy's player play my
normal saturday i wanted to play the
dutch okay so i get the names Oh again
I'm sorry about that I really wanted to
point it to play a five maybe I can get
in something like a five later but does
not look like that now maybe this is six
line is this a guy I know let's check
again people call me the snail obvious
reasons let's see
the IAC 6 line is quite quite funny
black relocates this Bishop to c7 and
after that goes some ahead with this
typical counter play in the middle in
the middle in the center I get any five
but that's okay so even if or yeah maybe
some more strengthening moves maybe wait
if he plays Bishop b2 than evo is much
stronger and so then f3 is more
difficult to play I won't ever should
have flicked in ace a 6 doing that now
okay I wants to play b5 really badly the
night on fa de some intending to go to
g6 or e 6 not one hundred percent sure
tempt what you do
okay i can always go to be a GF he takes
place i can up like when a form okay try
to play with h5 age 4 and 9 to e 6 it's
good news that he's not so quick it
hurts really helping so I'm not clearly
behind on the clock as I usually a.m.
wow that's a decentralizing move um wait
if i take here take on g3t Connie too
well take a four at the end right or
take a form and this is maybe the
easiest or the sympathy should take a 4
1st is overloaded here g3 each way for
is overloaded what is the best move
order though okay I just recapture this
is try to defend look a to maybe look a
to Queen my can stop like queen bee
three
okay to queen bee three very weird lines
okay I just play play simple simple
stuff so I can win the pawn now here
which is we're just not bad but also not
not fantastic or anything okay yeah
maybe this is quite okay i also have
bishop asics coming what does he
thinking about shouldn't it be basically
the same whatever he's doing I will
bubble take p6 anyhow I guess I can I
can consider 96cm maybe night a six
because I can take any way yeah but ok
let's don't do anything fancy just take
this stuff ok so i can take here play 96
cannot get it to a six-year maybe 97 95
yeah it's a tempo only three so gaining
a bit of time here but this is not the
fantastic position it's a pawn but this
is obviously week Queen d7 well you can
just get the pawn back Bishop d7 SS
passive but probably is that what I want
to do we have Bishop g5 at least I can
take it to
Joe ah this is not really a great porn
that I want him I'm hoping for Bishop g4
as a good way to return the pawn Bishop
g4 now time morning I can take I know
you can take stick and still take on on
16 Bishop f3 Queen Queen here okay
and to maybe I can wear this is this is
okay
light squares now at least I know where
my dogs question haha my dark squares
okay white resign he's asking everyone
ok the time maybe but yeah what the game
maybe I missed some some more direct win
Queen Queen a forward a light a force
where was a misstep of course but it did
not lose it seems but he must do what he
did I think otherwise it gets very very
tricky Queen takes deform the let's
start with the basic point if he takes
with this what is looking normal I have
those ideas like here these ideas maybe
Scott Bishop g5 this is the the basic
idea winning material but there are some
some funny funny ways to play yeah but
this this was also try for for defense
taking okay night 827 this is much
better Bishop takes b6 was a bad move
this is much better of course I much
very much prefer to take on b6 and keep
my dark squared bishop so that I don't
have the the squares weakened and with
97 he's in this is in the spinner so
this is much much better
and here it's I mean it's a pawn but
it's not easy to win at all he's got
compensation and I probably didn't play
it well this was there was some logic
behind this but it stopped impassive I
was thinking that maybe we should be for
as an idea but it's not working c6 was
always hanging also very questionable if
he intends of a trade I can do anything
if you would go to the endgame maybe
maybe I have some chance I can get the
night somewhere yeah it's a bit of an
edge still here this was funny we should
play f6 really have prevent Bishop b5
and snow bishop if I was coming ok this
is this now quick a queen of three yeah
he can also one should play Queen f4
it's not a good idea yeah I guess we'll
give aid to get more firepower and the
comp gives black win but I don't yet see
how I can take h2
check the computer is giving something
like that it's very difficult very
difficult to understand what the big
point is I can't imagine that black is
winning but I don't really see how it is
you have a big attack but I'm not stop
seeing a mate or anything okay let's say
wrap up this session thanks for watching